Es una emoción estar aquí en una conferencia
dedicada a "Inspirados por la Naturaleza", como se podrán imaginar.
Pero también estoy encantada de estar en la sección de jugueteo previo.
¿Se dieron cuenta que esta es la sección de jugueteo previo?
Porque me toca hablar de una de mis criaturas favoritas:
el achichilique pico amarillo. Uno no ha vivido
hasta que ha visto a estos tipos hacer su danza de cortejo.
Estaba en el Lago Bowman en el Parque Nacional de los Glaciares,
un lago largo y estrecho, con una especie de cerros volteados
y mi pareja y yo tenemos una canoa de remo.
Estábamos remando y se acercó uno de estos achichiliques pico amarillo.
Y lo que hacen como danza de cortejo es, se van juntos,
los dos, los dos compañeros, y comienzan a andar bajo el agua.
Patalean rápido, y más rápido, y más rápido, hasta que van tan rápido
que literalmente se elevan fuera del agua,
y allí van elevados, en una especie de pataleo sobre la superficie del agua.
Y entonces uno de estos achichiliques se acercó mientras nosotros íbamos remando.
Y aquí vamos como en una parvada, moviéndonos muy, muy rápidamente.
Y el achichilique creo que como que nos confunde con una oportunidad
y empieza a correr sobre el agua junto a nosotros,
en una danza de cortejo... durante varios kilómetros.
Podría parar, y luego empezar, y luego detenerse, y a continuación empezar.
A eso le llamo: jugueteo previo
(Risas)
Bueno, casi; estuve así de cerca de cambiarme de especie en ese momento
Obviamente la vida siempre nos enseña algo
en la sección de entretenimiento. Bueno, la vida tiene mucho que enseñarnos.
Pero de lo que quisiera hablar hoy
es lo que la vida puede enseñarnos respecto a tecnología y diseño.
Lo que sucedió desde que salió el libro
el libro era principalmente sobre la investigación en biomimética.
Y lo que ha sucedido desde entonces es que arquitectos, diseñadores, ingenieros
la gente que construye nuestro mundo... empezó a llamar diciendo:
queremos un biólogo para que se siente en la mesa de diseño
para que nos ayude, en tiempo real, y se inspire
O, y esto se me hizo gracioso, queremos que nos lleven
al mundo natural. Proponemos un reto en diseño
y buscamos a los campeones mejor adaptados del mundo natural, que podrían inspirarnos.
Así que esa es una foto que tomamos en un viaje a las Galápagos
con unos ingenieros especialistas en tratamiento de aguas servidas; ellos purifican las aguas servidas.
Y algunos de ellos se resistían, realmente, a estar allí.
Lo que al principio nos decían era, ya saben, nosotros ya aplicamos la biomimética.
Usamos bacterias para limpiar nuestra agua. Y entonces les dijimos,
bueno, no exactamente -- eso no es exactamente estar inspirado por la Naturaleza.
Eso más bien es bioprocesamiento, como quien dice biotecnología aplicada
usando un organismo para que haga el tratamiento de aguas servidas
es una vieja, vieja tecnología conocida como "domesticación".
Esto es aprender algo, aprender una idea de un organismo para luego aplicarla.
Así que ellos aún no lo entendían.
Entonces fuimos a caminar por la playa y les dije:
bueno, dénme uno de sus mayores problemas. Dénme un desafío de diseño,
un obstáculo para la sustentabilidad, que no les permita ser sustentables.
Y dijeron el sarro, que es la acumulación de minerales dentro de los tubos.
Y me comentaron, sabes, lo que pasa es que el mineral
igual que en tu casa, los minerales se acumulan.
Y entonces la abertura se cierra y tenemos que destapar los tubos con toxinas,
o tenemos que escarbarlos.
Si tan solo hubiera una manera de parar este sarro...
Y entonces levanté unas conchas de la playa. Y les pregunté:
¿Qué es el sarro? ¿Qué hay dentro de sus tubos?
Y contestaron: carbonato de calcio.
Y dije: eso es esto; esto es carbonato de calcio.
Y ellos no lo sabían.
Ellos no sabían de qué es una concha marina,
es modelada por proteínas y luego los iones del agua marina
se cristalizan en el sitio, bien, para formar la concha.
Así que un proceso similar, pero sin las proteínas,
está pasando dentro de sus tubos. Y ellos no lo sabían.
Esto no es por falta de información; es por falta de integración.
Saben, es como un silo, gente dentro de silos. No sabían
que estaba pasando lo mismo. Así que uno de ellos lo pensó
y dijo, bueno, está bien, si esto no es más que la cristalización
que ocurre automáticamente del agua marina, el autoensamblaje,
entonces ¿por qué las conchas no son infinitas en tamaño? ¿Qué las detiene?
¿Por qué simplemente no siguen adelante?
Y dije, bueno, de la misma forma en que sueltan las pro...
en que exudan una proteína y empieza la cristalización,
y ahí fue cuando todos se inclinaron hacia adelante...
liberan una proteína que detiene la cristalización
Literalmente se adhiere a la cara creciente del cristal.
De hecho, hay un producto llamado APT
que imita a esa proteina, esa proteina inhibidora
y es una forma ecológica de detener la formación de sarro.
Eso cambió todo, después de eso
no podíamos hacer regresar a los ingenieros al bote.
El primer día salían de paseo,
y era clic, clic, clic, clic. Cinco minutos después estaban de vuelta en el barco.
Ya acabamos, saben, ya había visto esa isla.
Después de esto
iban por todas partes. Ellos no...
buceaban todo el tiempo que los dejábamos.
Se dieron cuenta que hay organismos
allá afuera que ya resolvieron los problemas
a los que han dedicado sus carreras, tratando de resolver.
Aprender acerca del mundo natural es una cosa.
Aprender del mundo natural, he ahí el cambio.
Es un cambio profundo.
Se dieron cuenta que las respuestas a sus problemas estaban por doquier.
Sólo necesitaban cambiar los lentes con los que ven al mundo.
3.8 miles de millones de años de pruebas.
Craig Venter les dirá que de 10 a 30;
creo que hay más de 30 millones de soluciones bien adaptadas.
Lo importante para mí es que estas soluciones están en contexto.
Y el contexto es la Tierra...
el mismo contexto en el que estamos tratando de resolver nuestros problemas.
Así que es la imitación consciente de la genialidad en la Vida.
No es imitación ciega,
aunque aquí Al está tratando de lograr el peinado
no es imitación ciega. Es tomar los principios de diseño,
la genialidad del mundo natural y aprender algo de ahí.
En un grupo con tanta gente de TI, tecnologias de la información,
tengo que decirlo, aunque no lo trataré mucho, es que su campo,
es uno que ha aprendido bastante de los seres vivos,
por el lado del software. Hay computadoras que se protegen,
como un sistema inmunológico y estamos aprendiendo de la regulación de genes
y desarrollo biológico. Y aprendemos de redes neuronales,
algoritmos genéticos, computación evolutiva.
Eso es por el lado del software. Lo que es interesante para mí
es que no lo hemos mirado tanto. Digo, estas máquinas...
no son de tan alta tecnología, en mi parecer,
siendo que hay docenas y docenas de carcinógenos
en el agua de Silicon Valley.
Así que el hardware
no está al nivel de lo que la Vida llamaría un éxito.
¿Qué podemos aprender de la fabricación, no sólo de PCs, sino de todo?
Los aviones en los que llegaron, los autos, los asientos que están usando.
¿Como rediseñamos el mundo que estamos haciendo, el mundo fabricado?
¿Mas aún, qué deberíamos preguntar los siguientes 10 años?
Hay muchas tecnologías geniales alla afuera que la vida usa.
¿Cuál es el plan de estudios?
Hay tres preguntas que para mí son la clave.
¿Cómo hace las cosas la Vida?
Esto es lo opuesto; cómo hacemos nosotros las cosas.
Se llama calentar, golpear y tratar
así le llaman lo cientificos de materiales.
Se trata de tallar las cosas dejando un 96% de desechos.
y sólo 4% de producto final. Lo calientas, lo golpeas con presión,
usas químicos. Ok, calentar, golpear y tratar.
La Vida no puede desperdiciar así. ¿Como hace las cosas la Vida?
¿Cómo hace la vida la mayoría de las cosas?
Ese es un polen de geranio.
Y la forma es lo que le da la capacidad de...
flotar por el aire fácilmente, ok. Miren la forma.
La vida le agrega información a la materia.
En otras palabras, estructura.
Le da información. Al agregar información a la materia,
le da una función diferente que si no tuviera estructura.
Tercer punto: ¿cómo hace la vida que las cosas se fusionen con el sistema?
Porque la vida realmente no trata con cosas;
no hay cosas en el mundo natural divorciadas
de sus sistemas.
Un plan de estudios breve.
Mientras voy leyendo más y más, y siguiendo la historia,
hay algunas cosas increíbles que han surgido en la biología.
Al mismo tiempo escucho a muchos negocios
y entiendo cuáles son sus retos.
Estos dos grupos no se están comunicando.
Para nada.
¿Qué es lo que sería útil de la biología en este punto,
para salir de este nudo evolutivo en el que estamos?
Voy a repasar doce puntos, brevemente.
Ok, uno que me emociona es el auto-ensamblaje.
Hemos escuchado de esto en la nanotecnología.
De vuelta a la concha, la concha se auto-ensambla.
Abajo a la izquierda hay una imagen del nácar
formándose a partir del agua de mar. Es una estructura de capas minerales
y después polímero, y lo hace muy muy duro.
Es dos veces más duro que nuestras cerámicas de alta tecnología.
A diferencia de nuestra cerámica que sale de hornos,
esto sucede en el agua de mar. Sucede cerca y dentro del organismo.
Ok, y las personas empiezan a...
Este es el Laboratorio Nacional Sandia, alguien llamado Jeff Brinkler
ha encontrado la forma de tener un proceso de código auto-ensamblado.
Imaginen tener cerámicas a temperatura ambiente,
simplemente sumergiendo algo en un líquido,
sacarlo del líquido y tener evaporación
forzando a las moléculas del líquido a juntarse
para que se junten como en un rompecabezas.
en la misma forma que en la cristalización.
Imaginen crear todos nuestros materiales duros de esa forma.
Imaginen rociar una celda FV, una celda solar, con precursores
sobre un techo, y que se auto-ensamblen en una estructura que recolecta luz.
Aquí algo interesante para el mundo de TI:
bio-silicio. Esto es una diatomea, hecha de silicatos.
El silicio que hacemos actualmente,
es parte del problema carcinogénico en la fabricación de chips.
Este es un proceso de bio-mineralización que se está imitando.
Esto es en la UC de Santa Barbara. Miren estas diatomeas.
Esto es del trabajo de Ernst Haeckel.
Imaginen poder... de nuevo, es un proceso guiado,
que se solidifica a partir de un proceso líquido, imaginen crear
ese tipo de estructura a temperatura ambiente.
Imaginen poder fabricar lentes perfectas.
A la izquierda, esta es una ofiura, está cubierta de lentes
que la gente de Lucent Technologies ha encontrado
que no tienen distorsión detectable.
Es una de las lentes más perfectas que conocemos.
Y tiene muchas, sobre todo su cuerpo.
Lo interesante, de nuevo, es que se auto-ensambla.
Una mujer, Joanna Aizenberg, en Lucent,
está aprendiendo como crear con un proceso a baja temperatura
este tipo de lente. Tambien está investigando sobre fibra óptica.
Esta es una esponja de mar que tiene fibra óptica.
Abajo, en la base, hay fibra óptica.
que funciona mejor que la nuestra, mueven luz.
Pero se pueden atar en un nudo, son increiblemente flexibles.
Otra idea grande: CO2 como materia prima.
Un tipo llamado Geoff Coates, de Cornell, se dijo a si mismo,
saben, las plantas no consideran al CO2 como el peor veneno.
Nosotros sí. Pero las plantas están ocupadas formando cadenas
de almidones y glucosa, a partir del CO2. Él ha encontrado la forma...
Ha encontrado un catalizador, y visto la forma de tomar el CO2
y crear policarbonatos. Plásticos biodegradables,
a partir del CO2. ¡Qué parecido a las plantas!
Transformaciones solares: es lo más emocionante.
Hay personas que están imitando el dispositivo recolector de energía
de las bacterias púrpuras, es la gente de la UEA. Aún más interesante,
últimamente, en las últimas semanas, se ha encontrado
una enzima llamada hidrogenasa que puede crear
hidrógeno a partir de protones y electrones y puede...
hacer lo que una celda de combustible, en el ánodo de la celda,
de una celda de combustible reversible.
En nuestras celdas lo hacemos con platino
La Naturaleza lo hace con un hierro muy, muy común.
Un equipo ha logrado imitar
la hidrogenasa, capaz de manejar el hidrógeno
Es emocionante en cuanto a las celdas
poder hacer eso sin platino.
La importancia de la forma: hemos visto que las aletas de la ballena
tienen abultamientos. Y esas pequeñas protuberancias
realmente incrementan la eficiencia, por ejemplo,
en el ala de un avión, incrementan la eficiencia en un 32%
Lo cual es un ahorro increíble de combustible fósil,
si tan solo lo pusiéramos en el borde de un ala.
Colores sin pigmentos: este pavo real crea colores con la forma.
La luz llega y rebota en las capas;
se llama interferencia de laminas delgadas. Imaginen poder
auto-ensamblar productos y que las últimas capas
jueguen con la luz para crear color.
Imaginen poder crear una textura sobre una superficie,
para que se auto-limpie, sólo con agua. Eso hacen las hojas.
¿Ven este acercamiento?
Es una esfera de agua, esas son partículas de polvo.
Ese es un acercamiento a la hoja de loto.
Una compañía está haciendo un producto llamado Lotusan,
cuando la pintura está seca, imita los abultamientos
de las hojas, y el agua de lluvia lava el edificio.
El agua será nuestro gran reto:
saciar la sed.
Aquí están dos organismos que obtienen agua.
A la izquierda está el escarabajo namibio
A la derecha está una cochinilla de humedad
Extrae el agua del aire. No la bebe.
Aquí esta extrayendo agua de la neblina y del aire húmedo de Atlanta
antes de que entre a un edificio, son tecnologías clave.
Las tecnologías de separación van a ser muy importantes.
¿Qué tal si dijeramos no más minas?
¿Qué tal si fuéramos a separar metales de aguas residuales
pequeñas cantidades de metales en el agua? Eso hacen los microbios,
ellos extraen los metales del agua.
Hay una compañía aquí en San Francisco llamada MR3
que está imitando las moléculas microbiales en filtros
para minar aguas residuales.
La química verde es trabajar con agua.
Hacemos química con solventes orgánicos.
Esta es una foto de las hileras de una araña, ok,
y como están tejiendo seda. ¿No es bello?
La química ecológica está reemplazando la química industrial.
No es fácil, puesto que la naturaleza usa
sólo un grupo de elementos de la tabla periódica.
Y nosostros usamos todos, hasta los tóxicos.
Para encontrar las recetas que sólo usan una parte
de la tabla periódica y crear materiales milagrosos
como esa célula, es la tarea de la química ecológica.
Degradación paulatina: empaques que funcionen
hasta que ya no se necesiten, después se deshacen.
Este es un mejillón, lo pueden encontrar en estas aguas.
y los hilos que lo fijan a la roca, sólo duran 2 años
y después se empiezan a disolver.
Curación: esto está bueno.
El amiguito allá es un tardígrado.
Uno de los problemas con las vacunas en el mundo
es que no llegan a los pacientes. La razón es
que la refrigeración no es adecuada;
se rompe la llamada "cadena de frío".
Un sujeto llamado Bruce Rosner, observó al tardígrado -
que se seca completamente y aún sigue vivo durante meses
y meses y meses y aún así es capaz de autoregenerarse.
Él ha encontrado la forma de deshidratar las vacunas -
encapsularlas en azúcar
como el tardígrado tiene en sus células -
así las vacunas no tienen que ser refrigeradas.
Se pueden colocar en una guantera, ok.
Aprendiendo de los organimos. Esta es sobre el agua...
aprender de los organismos que viven sin agua
para poder crear una vacuna que dure sin refrigeración.
No llegaré al punto 12.
Lo que sí les diré es que la cosa más importante,
aparte de todas estas adaptaciones, es el hecho que todos estos,
han encontrado la forma de hacer lo que hacen,
mientras cuidan del hábitat
que cuidará a su descendencia.
Cuando están en el jugueteo previo,
están pensando en algo muy muy importante,
que es, preservar su material genético,
de aquí a 10.000 generaciones en el futuro.
Y eso requiere que hagan lo que hacen
sin destruir el hábitat que cuidará a sus hijos.
Ese es el más grande reto de diseño.
Afortunadamente, hay millones y millones de genios
dispuestos a regalarnos sus mejores ideas.
Buena suerte en la charla con ellos.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)
Chris Anderson: Hablando de jugueteo... necesitamos llegar al punto 12.
Janine Benyus: ¿En serio?
CA: ¡Si claro!, pero tu sabes, la versión de 10 segundos.
del 10, 11 y 12. Porque tus diapositivas son hermosas,
y las ideas muy trascendentes, no puedo permitir que bajes
sin ver 10, 11 y 12
JB: Ok, pon esto, yo sostendré esto, muy bien.
Ok, eso fue en cuanto a curación.
Detección y respuesta: la retroalimentación es algo muy grande.
Hay una langosta. Puede haber 80 millones en un km cuadrado
y aún así no chocan contra otra.
Y nosotros tenemos 3.6 millones de choques de autos al año.
(Risas)
Correcto. Hay una persona en Newcastle
se dio cuenta, que se debe a una neurona muy grande.
Y ella está buscando como hacer
circuitos de evasión de colisiones
basado en esta gran neurona de la langosta.
Esto es realmente grande, número 11:
Es la fertilidad de las cosechas
Fertilidad neta en las granjas.
Deberíamos incrementar la fertilidad. Y obtener comida.
Porque debemos aumentar la capacidad del planeta
para crear más y más oportunidades de vida.
Realmente, eso hacen los otros organismos.
En conjunto, eso es lo que hace un ecosistema:
crean cada vez más oportunidades para la vida.
Nuestra agricultura ha hecho lo opuesto.
Una agricultura basada en cómo crea tierra la pradera,
una ganadería basada en cómo una manada nativa
incrementa el bienestar de los campos.
Incluso tratamiento de aguas basado en como las marismas
no sólo limpian el agua,
sino que, increíblemente, incrementan la productividad.
Este es un pequeño informe de diseño. Digo, parece simple porque
el sistema, a lo largo de 3.8 miles de millones de años, lo ha perfeccionado.
Esto es, los organismos que no han podido encontrar
como mejorar o "endulzar" sus hábitats,
no están aqui para contárnoslo.
Ese fue el doceavo punto.
La Vida - y he aquí el secreto; el truco de magia
la vida crea condiciones para crear más vida.
crea tierra, limpia el aire, limpia el agua,
mezcla el cóctel de gases que ustedes y yo necesitamos para vivir.
Y lo hace mientras está en el jugueteo
y satisfaciendo sus necesitades. No son mutuamente excluyentes.
Tenemos que encontrar la forma de satisfacer nuestras necesidades
y, al mismo tiempo, hacer un Edén de este lugar.
CA: Janine. ¡Muchísimas gracias!
(Aplausos)